[Musique]
12 août 1737 normandie c'est l'histoire
d'antoine antoine né dans une famille
modeste dans cette france d'avant la
révolution
il ne s'est pas encore qu'un demi siècle
plus tard il va sauver des milliers de
femmes et d'hommes de la famine
apothicaires agrobiologistes chimiste
antoine parmentier est le premier à
lancer la consommation de pommes de
terre en france en un an cette racine à
la table du roi
il en fait un aliment noble et
révolutionne l'alimentation des français
23 juin 1912 à londres allan commence sa
vie avec une enfance compliquée pour ce
génie des mathématiques et le départ des
amis de ses parents peu compris par ses
professeurs
introverti souvent seul et pourtant à
force de recherches en suivant sa
passion il va devenir l'un des
précurseurs de l'informatique moderne
durant la seconde guerre mondiale alan
turing se lève et en décryptant les
codes allemand il devient l'un des
piliers de la victoire des alliés 13
juillet 1927 alsace lorraine dans une
famille qui sera décimé par la guerre
née simone qui par sa pugnacité sa
volonté deviendra non seulement l'une
des icônes de la cause des femmes
mais une des promotrices de l'europe et
de la réconciliation franco allemande
simone veil se lève seul dans
l'hémicycle et en dépénalisant
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
change la vie de milliers de femmes
leur point commun ils se sont levés
ils n'ont pas eu peur de leurs idées et
à force de volonté ils ont changé le
monde et surtout surtout ils l'ont fait
sans le savoir ni simone veil ni alan
turing me antoine parmentier n'ont su au
moment où ils se sont levés dans une vie
qui était probablement plein de doutes
qu'ils allaient changer la vie de
millions de paires
nous sommes le 6 octobre 2018 à lorient
ce matin des milliers de femmes des
milliers d'hommes se sont levés pensant
probablement qu'ils étaient bien peu de
chose face aux défis du monde et
pourtant ils sont vous êtes nous sommes
les à l'asnl et simone et antoine du
monde de demain en ce qui me concerne je
ne suis pas vraiment levé au début je
suis plutôt tomber tomber dans le bain
de l'engagement des enfants avec des
parents engagés jusqu'au bout des ongles
alors qu'est ce que ça donne ils m'ont
transmis tout petit une vision de l'état
du monde et aussi un sentiment de
responsabilité
moi qui suis né et qui vit en france
parmi les plus chanceux des plus
chanceux ils m'ont aussi donné cette
conviction que le pouvoir de changer les
choses de changer le monde nous
appartient et cette conviction je les
gardais profondément ancrées et au fil
des années j'ai grandi et j'ai compris
que quelque chose avait fondamentalement
changé les bouleversements sont trop
grands
les enjeux sont immenses et changement
trop rapide
on ne peut plus lever seul il faut le
faire massivement il faut le faire à
plusieurs et d'ailleurs les faits
parlent d'eux mêmes les inégalités elles
n'ont cessé d'augmenter depuis 2016 le
patrimoine cumulé des 1% les plus riches
des passes au niveau mondial celui des
99% restants il y à 4,7 milliards
d'individus qui vivent avec moins de
deux dollars par jour
4,7 milliards les démocraties recul dans
de nombreux pays les droits des femmes
aussi
et les réfugiés qui sont vous le savez
pour 2/3 climatiques sont 250 millions
soit 5 fois plus qu'aujourd'hui
en 2050 et nos ressources elles
s'épuisent
on est sept milliards et demi sur une
planète finie avec des modes de
production de consommation de gestion
des déchets qui sont antinomiques avec
cette croissance un chiffre un fait les
réserves d'eau douce ont diminué de
moitié par habitant depuis 1960 au cap
en afrique du sud il n'y a plus d'eau au
robinet et moi si on m'avait dit ça ya
dix ans j'aurais pensé que c'était
probablement le scénario d'un mauvais
film de science fiction les technologies
elle questionne sans cesse notre place
d'homme dans le travail face à la nature
bref des bouleversements des inégalités
des ressources qui s'épuisent des
technologies qui nous challenge tout est
bouleversé
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait je suis sûr
que beaucoup d'entre vous se lève déjà
font beaucoup et moi aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous inviter à le faire
ensemble à faire corps et si on
réfléchit c'est quoi les organisations
qui sont suffisamment puissante massive
pour générer ce changement à grande
échelle
et si l'entreprise était la meilleure
organisation pour se lever pour faire
corps moi j'ai longtemps pensé que c est
l inverse que ce n'était pas son rôle
c'était du ressort de l'état après tout
c'est son boulot à l'état n'en est en
même temps je pense qu'on est confronté
à un manque d'agilité parfois
d'efficacité et puis surtout quand on
voit que dans nombreuses biographies
l'état c'est moi de louis xiv stade
emmanuel macron sens terriblement juste
je me pose des questions
j'ai ensuite pensé que c'était du
ressort des ong
après tout ce sont elles les lanceurs
d'alerté elles sont souvent le bernier
rabot pour les oubliés du monde et elles
sont des acteurs incontournables
alors il ya douze ans j'ai monté une ong
qui a eu dix ans de programme au togo
est aujourd'hui en mongolie et là j'ai
vécu de l'intérieur la dépendance aux
subventions et surtout surtout à la
générosité de ceux qui s'y engagent
corps et âme et du coup les limites de
ces acteurs qui ne peuvent pas relever
ces défis
seul et puis il se trouve que j'ai fait
mes classes sur les bancs de l'archétype
du capitalisme a chaussé et là j'ai
découvert le puissant la puissance
levier
le pouvoir de l'entreprise et j'ai aussi
découvert que ce monde là n'était pas si
terrible et ça a été le déclic
pourquoi ne pas mettre cette agilité
cette capacité d'innovation
cette puissance au service d'autres
choses
l'entreprise meilleure organisation
humaine pour se lever et faire corps
j'en vois dans la salle même dans la
pénombre qui ne se disent l'entreprise
sérieusement l'entreprise le symbole de
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
hier par le travail à la machine
aujourd'hui par libé risation
l'entreprise qui nous pousse à la
surconsommation qui exploitent notre
source
l'entreprise qui inondent nos océans de
plastique
cette entreprise là n'ont pas cette
entreprise là une entreprise à
réinventer une entreprise locale frugal
humaine une entreprise raisonnée
sept autres entreprises elle agit avec
et pour son territoire elle met son
empreinte au coeur de sa stratégie
elles pensent différemment pour ses
clients elle va chercher à innover pour
les plus fragiles et cette entreprise là
elle oublie pas le profit et c'est pas
ce qu'on lui demande
parce que finalement ça reste le gage de
l'efficacité de l'innovation de l'effet
d'échelle mais le met au service
d'autres choses au service de quelque
chose de plus grand
j'en vois dans la salle d'autres ou
peut-être les mêmes qui se disent que
tout ça c'est de l'utopie
moi je ne crois pas que ce soit ça les
taudis et d'ailleurs emmanuel faber vous
savez le patron de danone à lui veut
faire passer son entreprise d'un vendeur
de yaourt un acteur de l'alimentation
durable pour tous et bien emmanuel faber
il a dit cette phrase qui m'a parlé il
dit l'économie sans le social c'est de
la barbarie
mais le social sans l'économie c'est
d'utopie
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement jet d'un homme
ça veut dire 100 millions d'euros
investis dans des filières pour reverser
la valeur aux agriculteurs ça veut dire
des innovations produits pour serveurs
des clients fragiles au mexique au
bangladesh ça veut dire 12 milliards
d'euros investis pour devenir le leader
du bio aux états unis est-ce que ça
suffit bien sûr que non il en sort d'une
posture on sort de la communication on
sort de ce qu'on a longtemps appelé le
greenwashing
le so shocking on est dans le concret et
à ce titre je ne sais pas si vous avez
suivi ça hier mais à l'assemblée a été
voté un amendement pour créer un nouveau
statut d'entreprise celui d'entreprise a
mission cette loi elle doit pacte va
nous aider à aller dans ce sens-là 21
octobre 1968 en aquitaine
laurence une autre né dans une famille
où on fait de la politique depuis la
révolution française et pourrait le
changement de société ne passera que par
l'état ou par la société civile alors
cette laurent ça l'a été
chercheuse est la vraie en ministère
elle a été conseillère en diversité
journalistes et au cours de ce parcours
et ben pourtant l areq acquis la
conviction que c'est l'entreprise qui
serait un des plus puissants leviers de
résolution nos défis sociétaux et alors
en 2008 au tournant de la crise elle
fait un choix dengue sans aucun bagage
financier
elle va lancer le premier fonds
d'investissement d'inpact investing un
fonds d'investissement qui va chercher à
avoir de la rentabilité financière mais
aussi et surtout un impact positif bien
sûr sur la planète et sur les hommes
laurence méhaignerie se lève pour une
finance raisonnée
12 mai 1983 toulouse j'en commence sa
vie sur les bancs des grandes écoles et
sa carrière dans les hautes sphères de
la finance et à 30 ans il lâche tout ça
pour aller voir ce qu'il y a de bons
dans nos la grande distribution et le
mettre au service de nos poubelles et il
va collecter chaque jour 50 tonnes de
denrées qui serait gaspillée incinérés
qui finirait dans nos campagnes qui
finirait dans nos rivières pour les
redistribuer les revaloriser les
transformer dans le cercle de l'économie
circulaire jean moreau et ses 100
collègues de phoenix se lève pour une
économie sans déchet mais pour tout ça
devienne massif pour que tout ça nous
permet de vraiment de faire corps vous
serez d'accord avec moi
il va falloir qu'on est encore plus loin
il va falloir qu'on change de regard il
va falloir qu on détricote la manière
dont on voit l'entreprise depuis des
décennies il va falloir qu'on innove
parce que c'est revient clients fragiles
pauvre isolé sans abîmer la planète et
en étant rentable si c'était simple ça
se saurait il ya quelques années j'ai
décidé de me lever moi aussi j'ai quitté
le monde du conseil pour rentrer dans
celui de l'entrepreneuriat social et
accompagner soutenir ces projets
d'entreprises différents et puis il ya
deux ans j'ai sauté dans le grand bain
celui de l'entrepreneuriat moi même et
j'ai monté ma start up avec comme
objectif quoi transmettre cette
conviction et accompagner tous ceux qui
dans les entreprises veulent changer le
monde mais manquent de clés pour
s'approprier ses nouveaux modèles pour
que eux aussi demain se lève
6 octobre 2033 le futur pour faire ce
voyage je veux demander de fermer les
yeux
c'est bien il y en a qui dorment déjà
pour eux ça va être facile
les autres je vais vous demander de
fermer les yeux maintenant votre voisin
va fermer les yeux lui aussi donc ça va
bien se passer
fermez les yeux
j'ai 50 ans je vous laisse faire le
calcul pour vous en ce qui me concerne
j'ai encore probablement une bonne
vingtaine d'années à travailler alors
dans 15 ans on imagine un scénario on
fait un métier sans trop savoir pourquoi
où les machines ont remplacé beaucoup de
choses inintéressantes qu'on avait
l'habitude de faire et aussi des choses
qu'on aimait faire dans 15 ans on chat
avec un inconnu à l'eau douce de la
planète
on ne connaît pas son voisin dans 15 ans
on ne va plus à la pompe
parce qu'un petit robot vient
automatiquement rechargé notre réservoir
d'une essence quasi impossible à
produire dans 15 ans on se nourrit de
piles au goût acidulé parce qu'on a
épuisé nos ressources et dans 15 ans on
entend chaque semaine car b disparaît de
la carte par manque d'eau désastre
humanitaire
autre catastrophe et là je dois
reconnaître que j'ai un peu peur ou
alors dans 15 ans on n'a pas un métier
et 3 activités complémentaires
épanouissante
certaines rémunéré d'autres pas
dans 15 ans on utilise les machines pour
nous soutenir
avec une grande vigilance à l'aider
connecté pour laisser place au hasard à
l'imprévu sans laisser le fantasme de
l'homme augmenté nous brûler les ailes
dans 15 ans on connaît son voisin et sa
voisine et avec eux on troque on partage
on échange dans 15 ans ne va plus à la
pompe
parce qu'on n'a plus de voiture dans 15
ans on se nourrit de légumes produits en
permaculture à moins de 100 km de chez
nous ou sur la ferme terrasse de notre
immeuble dans 15 ans on laisse les
enfants être très différent très
créative
très empathique parce que l'école elle
aussi a changé elle leur apprend à lire
à compter à écrire mais pas que elle
leur apprend à faire avec
plutôt que contre à poser des questions
plutôt qu'à rester des réponses à
prendre soin d'eux des autres de leur
environnement dans 15 ans on vit
ensemble sur une même planète
alors la préserve la vague du changement
est là
la question est de savoir s conserve
dessus ou est-ce qu'on se laisse moi y
est on va pas se mentir ya du boulot
alors ouvrons les yeux et levons nous
pour le monde que l'on veut
[Applaudissements]